this guy's on the phone peter the birds
aren't real guys have you heard about
this birds aren't real he started a
movement called birds aren't real the
movement you'll love this robin is based
on the conspiracy theory that the united
states government killed and replaced 12
billion birds with robot spy drones
oh my god there were so many weird
[ __ ] conspiracy theories he thought
it'd be funny to go in there with a big
sign that says birds aren't real because
what were the kind of signs you were
seeing oh i mean the signs were nuts
there's these people out post election
out in the streets the chaotic time
everyone's feeling the madness pretty
hardcore it was just a lot of like kind
of hateful rhetoric being spread it's so
funny to go to a conspiracy theory rally
and then once you hold up a sign that
says birds aren't real it reduces the
whole thing to chaos it's like it's just
so absurd it was sort of this idea of
like holding up a mirror to the lunacy
sort of just using the situation not
aggressively through comedy for a while
were people quoting it and saying birds
aren't real is real like were enough
idiots going along with it so yeah i
mean that was kind of the goal of the
project you know i've been doing birds
on rails for four years now and starting
off the goal was to kind of make this
fictional character that lives in the
real world and i wanted kind of people
to process the character as a real
person so i spent four years in
character you know local media reported
on birds aren't really having existed
since 1976 see that's the thing i like
about this movement it's so easy to get
fake information out there between the
internet and even the media sucks nobody
back checks nobody does anything i
thought it was pretty funny i saw a tape
of peter on a news show and what'd you
do you drank clam juice right before
they interviewed you and then you just
threw up when they started interviewing
oh my god yeah so i wanted to make
myself throw up on live tv because in
theory my character is this nervous guy
from arkansas you know in his mind that
day he had a big responsibility he was
carrying the world on his back to carry
the truth of the movement to the people
but my character flogged it got super
nervous on tv and vomited
oh my god i'm so nervous i'm so sorry
well we hope you're okay
uh in order to do that i had to wake up
early drive to walmart by four cans of
clam chowder um and just stuffed them
down but right before we went live i uh
had just eaten as much clam chowder as i
could humanly fit in my stomach by the
time we went on air i just overflowed
the movement's pretty big now i mean
peter's making a living because he can
sell uh birds aren't real merch well i
don't know how this is helping
it's the most important movement on the
face of the earth some may say i'm
hoping that some people will see the
birds aren't real movement and say wait
a second maybe we should look into some
of the stupid [ __ ] that we believe yeah
you're hoping but you don't see it
happening you can't show me people wow
no no no giving up on their theories
that's my point i i can't show them to
you but i've met them uh they won't come
on the air it is work peter's movement
is working i i'm convinced of it